[Musique]
au sommaire de ce nouveau numéro un golf
et surtout un lieu d'entraînement pas
fait pour améliorer son swing en toute
saison c'est le golf du bois de boulogne
que nous présente son directeur anthony
à malte mais aussi dans cette émission
des conseils pour vos cadeaux de fin
d'année
le chariot électrique de plus compact de
nom d un télémètre la recharge solaire
on en parle avec rémy s'est vite
directeur de golf plus un pari d potter
made in france made in bretagne du sur
mesure et du haut de gamme à prix
raisonnables sont les potters argol gros
plans soldes club à taille unique qui
sont très à la mode mais que valent ils
vraiment utile 12 points devant brydon
200 bourg réponse avec un spécialiste de
ces clubs du bien du terme
enfin comment s'habiller chaudement pour
univers sans oublier bien sûr le conseil
du pot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai au milieu des grills et des hommes
des proches dit gorges du bois de
boulogne en compagnie d'anthony abbasse
bonjour bonjour patrice du directeur
d'école de bois-de-boulogne
alors il faut le dire ce site va avoir
bientôt 20 ans effectivement l'année
prochaine on aura le plaisir de fêter
ses 20 ans il ya toute une histoire une
histoire de passionnés autour du golf du
bois de boulogne puisque notre président
patrick krauss grand amour joueur
émérite pendant de nombreuses années à
travers le monde est bien décidée dans
les années 80 de trouver une solution
pour un certain nombre de golfeurs qui
devait faire à l'époque une heure une
heure et demie de voiture pour aller
jouer en europe et pas beaucoup de
terrain de trouver la solution pour
s'entraîner pendant la semaine puisque
le vrai terme au delà du nom que nous
avons depuis 20 ans d'un site
d'entraînement ainsi d'entraînement vous
pouvez vous entraîner de manière limitée
aux petits jeux et opening et taper des
balles en place deux parties c'est
évidemment ce qu'il faut dire alors
c'est bien cocon on est là au mois de
novembre
en décembre c'est à dire que évidemment
c'est un lieu formidable formidable
toute l'année mais dans les périodes
d'hiver où c'est plus compliqué de jouer
ou l'intégration opengraph fermé où il
ya des dégrés divers parfois pour venir
s'entraîner c'est formidable alors vous
avez raison patrice ce qu'on a souhaité
faire patrick ross et donc les autres
associés c'est de miser sur la qualité
de l'infrastructure a lancé un grand mot
mais c'est important on essaie d'avoir
les meilleures balles de practice qui
existent on a un partenariat
l'extraction depuis 20 ans et ils sont
formidables
c'est très important pour nous et pour
ça que sensation qu'avec des balles
normal quoi voilà c'est exactement donc
c'est très important pour nous on change
également très régulièrement les tapis
on essaie sur un endroit finalement
assez petit puisque on a quatre hectares
on accueille deux cent mille visiteurs
par an dont beaucoup de monde on à 2005
plus de 2500 membres
alors va peut-être parler de ça il faut
le dire tout le monde peut venir ici sur
le site du du golf du bois de boulogne
sans forcément être inscrits on peut
venir taper des balles s'entraîner au
petit jeu son problème c' est ce que je
dirais on est entre le parc et jardin
oui le golf et le site d'entraînement
c'est ouvert à tout le monde tenait à
tout le monde et voilà tout le monde
peut venir et surtout pourrait venir
sans jouer au golf
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que c'est un endroit où il fait bon
vivre
oui je pense que les gens aujourd'hui
ont besoin de verres de tranquillité
mais aux beaux jours on voit beaucoup de
gens qui viennent de voir s'asseoir sur
des chaises aux exemples de soleil enfin
j'ai vu beaucoup c'est très agréable
c'est quelque chose qu'on irait il y
aura une raison qui va réouvrir il ya un
restaurant il ya également un magasin de
l'envieux matériel de golf et on a
souhaité si vous voulez trouver la
solution pour proposer aux différents
clients aux familles n'ont pas une
structure mais en fonction de leur
planning
je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans le
développement du golf c'est un des
soucis prendre la voiture aller quelque
part le matériel le temps le temps est
quelque chose d'essentiel on a une
leader devant soi on peut venir ici quoi
ça c'est fort bien exactement là
à durée moyenne de notre clientèle et
d'une heure et noël c'est ça il ya
combien de postes de practice ici alors
vous avez 75 postes de practice une
partie couverte verte une partie avec
des boxes vrai individualisé puisque
vous avez 25 enseignants
alors ça c'est très important parce que
c'est sans doute l'endroit en france je
suppose un où il ya le plus enseigner il
peut prendre effectivement on peut
apprendre se perfectionner
ça c'est formidable oui parce que
comparativement au monde dont on a parlé
surtout les plages horaires on est
ouvert tous les jours de 8h à 20h
l'hiver et sachez qu'il ya du monde à la
fois tôt le matin et tard le soir c'est
éclairé quand il fait un c'est le
d'éclairer le petit jeu le betting
c'est également chauffé s'échauffer sur
six boxes et individualisé quand il fait
très mauvais ont réussi vers on a du
monde
ça donne beaucoup de convivialité du
mois on essaie d'en donner et l'ensemble
de ses enseignants fait la richesse de
ce qu'on peut proposer puisqu'ils ont
différentes techniques différentes
manières d'enseigner ce qui vous permet
de changer et de trouver à votre
convenance la solution alors il ya une
chose très simple c'est d'aller sur le
site du golf du bois de boulogne
il ya tous les numéros des des
enseignants elle nous le disent et c'est
ouvert évidemment tout le monde et puis
il ya quand même des membres et des
cartes de membres ce qu'elle est
davantage d'être mordu de boulogne alors
c'est également une bonne question
puisqu'on sait vous et moi que le golf
est organisée de manière différente en
france quand on parle de membres on
pense ainsi un golf privé à nouveau on
est ouvert à tout le monde
aujourd'hui la carte mans permet d'avoir
un tarif préférentiel permet d'avoir
accès à un site d'entraînement de
manière privilégiée
on a la chance d'avoir développé une
école de golf qui on espère pour la
troisième année à avoir la plus grande
école de golf pour les jeunes en france
c'est pour les jeunes d'aucun c'est pour
les jeunes ray mais c'est également pour
les parents
ainsi donc c'est une école de golf
familiale et c'est ce qu'on a souhaité
proposer au départ et c'est ce qui a
changé beaucoup de choses dans une
famille souvent vous aviez une personne
sans la nommer
puisque ça change qui ne souhaitait pas
jouer au golf et l'ail
on adapte c'est à dire que vous
choisissez votre jour une heure et vous
avez un cours adapté des quatre ans on
prend les enfants sachez qu'on a 85
pitchouns 7 4 à 6 ans 35 minutes de
cours et puis vous avez pour les plus
grands pour les enfants débutants
confirmés on essaie d'avoir donc un
cours adapté
donc c'est ce qui change tout c'est
toute la famille le samedi le dimanche
ou le mercredi vient jouer ensemble des
gens c'est moi est ce que vous êtes déjà
demandé de s coup s vous est arrivé de
privatiser l'espace du golf du bois de
boulogne pour des soirées pour des fêtes
notre activité première sera toujours
serge robe néanmoins avec le golf un
événement festif un anniversaire une
soirée faire découvrir le golf radars et
des amis ces actes là avec nous on a on
a un certain nombre de demandes surtout
par rapport au fait que le site est
assez magique de nuit
et on était au bon jour et même en hiver
voilà il est fonctionnel donc alors vous
êtes là encore quelques années en moins
jusqu'en 2026 peut-être plus si
affinités avec le connais pas je vous
remercie infiniment autres diamètres et
bravo pour ce que vous faites remercier
un site pour nous aider à mettre en
valeur le golf c'est très important pour
l'ensemble des structures
merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour rémy civiquement jours plus tard
vous êtes responsable du magasin golf
plus qu'à paris on va perret est avec
vous on va donner deux ou trois idées de
cadeaux qu'on peut faire en fin d'année
alors là vous avez bon bah c'est un
chariot enfin un chariot s'est passé
c'est pas si et électrique voilà et et
surtout comme vous allez pouvoir le
constater quand on le repli devient
extrêmement compact et le loge est très
très facilement dans son corps on vous
enlève le 11 mars et le le sac voilà
comme ça
voilà vous nous enlever la batterie bien
sûr et vous commencez par le parlement
jeudi du chariot à l'écart
[Musique]
voilà ah oui alors en place très bons
plats vous pouvez gagner vraiment de la
place dans dans le coffre de votre
voiture
et qui est-ce qui vise à alors certes la
marque flat 4 c'est une marque allemande
médecin et voilà donc ça produit de très
très bonnes qualités et surtout voilà le
ce qui plaît énormément c'est ce côté
qui se replient comme ça exactement
j'ai vu que vous aviez apporter quelque
chose d'autre c'est ce qu'on appelle un
télémètre c'est ça
exemple permet d'avoir la distance
l'existence bien sûr aux drapeaux
différents obstacles sur sur le parcours
c'est le caddie de l'amateur et celui ci
alors extrêmement léger et puis la
particularité en plus de celui ci c'est
qu'il a une cellule voyez solaire
l'énergie solaire c'est génial donc
possibilité donc éventuellement de
rajouter une pile on a une histoire en
panne il ya plus de piles par exemple ça
marche quand même et donc on a toute la
technologie qu'on peut retrouver sur sur
d'autres appareils notamment le ce qu'on
appelle le système john key qui vivre
le vrai le bon objectif de ca voilà
c'est bien donc on est sûr de pouvoir
prendre le drapeau et que le prix à peu
près alors 239 euros ce qui peine
néanmoins été primés ouais ouais ouais
en entrée de gamme mais vraiment et
surtout très très très bon produit et
avec justement le bénéfice alors voilà
ça c'est lourd ça plaisait bien pour les
hawks et un peu oublieux qui oublie de
recharger un peu étourdi ça saigne elle
qu' il n'y avait pas de livres que vous
pourriez conseiller oui alors un ouvrage
est sorti sur sur la ryder cup tout les
toutes les éditions toute une histoire
voilà et il ya de magnifiques photos des
explications sur sur toutes les épreuves
qui se sont passées depuis que monsieur
rider inventé exactement cette
compétition donc il préface parents de
thomas levet exactement avait justement
un livre sur thomas levet avec également
toute sa carrière puis était au racing
et puis c'est devenu un des plus grand
champion de golf au monde
il a été à deux doigts de gagner le
british open et puis maintenant il était
un des artisans de la ryder cup aussi
comme comme van de velde enfin exact
comme dubuisson les deux français et ils
commentent avec passion aujourd'hui le
le lol très bien ouais c'est chez
editions pc voilà merci beaucoup réussi
parce que quand vous retrouvez à god
plus de 21 m et puisqu'on est au coeur
du bois de boulogne
autant le dire il ya aussi un magasin
d'autres puisque yves alors nous avons
un magasin de golf plus est
également ainsi fini centre de fitting
walt est important pour choisir ces
clubs on a déjà parlé dans cette
émission
merci vous rêvez civière s'ils peuvent
espérer nous on va continuer à vous
donner des idées de cadeaux et je
voudrais vous présenter des auteurs
français mêmes bretons et pour cela je
suis avec hugo tiny ça va bien bonjour
patrice ça va très bien vous êtes
responsable du développement d'une
société qui s'appelle argolf art comme
armorique et golf comme golf est qui qui
fabrique des potter racontez-nous alors
qu'est ce que c'est cette société
bretonne alors argol séné il ya une
dizaine d'années de ça
de l'imaginaire de sébastien et olivier
colas qui sont les gérants d'une société
bretonne qui oeuvrent dans la mécanique
et l'usinage de précision avec ils sont
sous traitants de l'industrie
aéronautique européenne et il avait de
très beaux matériaux très dense qui
servent justement à à faire des pour des
avions eu voilà les avions et donc ils
sont amusés pour eux personnellement à
usiner 2 potter et des brawn est pour
eux voilà chacun des deux frères et ils
se sont aperçus qu'ils avaient de très
belles sensations une très belle rule
qui en était dégagé ils sont dit voilà
il ya quelque chose à faire aux pôles et
les trouver ou bien si tu y as un site
internet c'est le mieux à faire argol
point fr et il ya toute la collection
qui est accessible sur le site est
évidemment que c'est un canton
recommande sur internet
parfois ce qui évidemment liège pour ce
qui est des tailles différentes il ya
des selon les configurations et tout est
configurable sur le site directement
d'accord il vous avez à réception du
potter une période d'essai d'un mois
là vous avez même pas mal de de potache
que vous avez apporté avec vous des
potter qui correspondent à tous les
profils de joueurs et de joueuses donc
différentes plantes est différent
équilibrage le club des dépôts turf s
balance qui sont très tolérants des
potter qu'on appelle tong qui sont moins
tolérants
voilà et cosmétiques m'en veux aller où
on peut aussi aller dans des choses de
couleurs de tous est très très important
on a une gamme qui est une gamme miroir
c'est à dire que les seize modèles
droitier sont également proposés en
gauche engagé tout un rite ça c'est très
exactement les mêmes
serra alors là on a un peu peur
relativement classique qui ressemble un
petit peu de ping c'est tout à fait donc
c'est une reprise donc c'est le modèle
arthur voilà son nom c'est une reprise
du plat de la lame en somme ce serait
une étape nécessaire dans l'aisne
d'années qui a fait largement ses
preuves
quelle est la différence avec le plus ce
ne sont pas des potter moulés ou même
encore forgé ce sont des porteurs sur
lesquels on part d'un
bloc de métal un adage bernard bloch
d'alliages et on vient avec des machines
très sophistiquées l'usiné les têtes à
même la masse et là on est sur un acier
aéronautique et on a donc une très très
grosse densité en tête dans ce jeu dans
ce moteur ce qui fait qu'à l'impact de
bâle
les balles ont un comportement qui est
foncièrement différent d'autres potter à
savoir une rule qui durent beaucoup plus
bordelongue voilà dakar parce qu'elle a
beaucoup plus de top spin
là après il ya des débatteurs mallet
maintenant tout ça tout à fait on a on a
également une belle diversité de potter
mallet - les couleurs pour peu voilà je
suis là il est dans le voit de loin les
couleurs sons et les mots de loin on le
voit de loin capacité à s'aligner plutôt
idée arrêt avec des bagues lindelof de
rayures 1 / du orange donc là cette fois
ci sur nos maillots ne on n'est plus sûr
de l'acier aéronautique on est sûr de
l'aluminium aéronautique un aluminium va
être beaucoup plus doux à l'impact
la g la balle va sortir moins vite nous
ne la fasse deux clubs après l'impact
en revanche on va avoir une route qui va
être plus longue quelle est la gamme de
prix argol cd potter dits premium qui se
situe entre 350 349 m et très exactement
et 399 notre seul prix des options de
dans la gamme on est de l'île d'orléans
de gama mais voilà ces cds potter qui
sont entièrement faits sur mesure
adaptés ces français donc on peut faire
du made in france
or dans le golfe à cesser la preuve tout
à ça paiera donc argolf on va sur le
site on commandait le putter pour veut
on peut éventuellement changer si on
n'est pas satisfait et jargeau en un
mois pour le faire c'est à dire que
c'est génial
voici merci beaucoup merci à vous
bénisse merci
[Musique]
alors toujours les idées de cadeaux il
ya une note sur laquelle je voudrais
avoir le coeur net ce sont les clubs de
taille unique
c'est la grande motte demande heureux
mais ce que c'est bien d'avoir des clubs
de taille unique alors pour ça que je
suis avec julien guillerme
bonjour bonjour patrie alors vous êtes
le spécialiste des clubs à taille unique
vous les voulez fabriquez-vous des fêtes
sur mesure alors c'est vrai qu'on en
parle beaucoup il ya eu 200 veaux qui
était à la ryder cup qui a gagné pas mal
de tournois et donc qu'ils oublient avec
des clubs de taille unique et donc tout
le monde se dit c'est très bien mais
est-ce que c'est vraiment aussi bien
qu'on le dit je dis pas que c'est fait
pour tout le monde mais au moins ça vaut
le coup d'essayer
parce que ça donne un vrai confort de
jeu c'est à dire que vous y verrez qu'on
est un fer 7 inferno ou un fer 4
c'est la même taille voilà c'est là
d'ailleurs derrière voilà là on se rend
compte qu'il ya une série derrière il ya
un fer 4 10 a fait recette et un fer 9
voilà la série elle existe du lobe watch
ouais donc 60° offert 4 d'accord et donc
à les fabriquer en tout cas par mes
soins sur mesure et et on s'aperçoit en
fait qu' il ya pas mal de gens qui sont
très contents de jouer avec parce que
ben c'est sûr la vallée donc de changer
de distance on est toujours le même ring
quoi il ya quand même une question qui
se pose comment généralement la distance
qu'on fait avec un avec un club ça
dépend aussi de la taille de ce club
voulait l'aider
les bois par exemple au plus haut plus
grand blond donc valois parce que le
club est long et alors comment comment
on compense sa avec les clubs à taille
unique il faut pas oublier que ça vous
donne aussi des assurances pour certains
joueurs justement qui ont du mal à
contacter correctement la balle avec un
club assez long d'avoir un meilleur
contact et quelques frayeurs contact de
balle déjà c'est plus avantagés que
d'avoir un club un peu plus rassuré
condrey affaire quatre dans les mains
avec un fer à taille unique que si on
attend quand même un peu mieux là bas il
un peu mieux et puis j'ai pris à la
particularité voyez j'ai deux têtes deux
clubs il y en a c'est bon le 60° le lob
wedge l'autre c'est de faire 5 mais on
s'aperçoit que c'est donc la même série
sterling mais c'est pas les mêmes têtes
oui il y en avait assez planes qui est
plein et l'autre qui vient c'est vide et
voilà est en fait la plus à éviter et
plus en fait la face et fine ce qui
vient restituer ce qu'on appelle le
coefficient de restitution sellal effet
trampoline qui vient en fait compensé
avec un effet de trampoline beaucoup
plus important que les autres clubs
[Musique]
il ya des gens plus grand plouf dit
lapenta il n'est pas forcément la même
taille pour tout le monde nous attend
c'est que les clubs
exactement et du coup je vais adapter
donc la longueur d'accord je vais
adapter aussi le poids du shaft la
rigidité je vais aussi donc adapté de la
taille du grip et c'est donc je vais je
vais aller aux petits oignons les
québécois tout le travail du club mais
coeur c'est d'aller voir plus loin
de fait sur mesure que la personne soit
garde ses clubs pendant très longtemps
alors un mot quand même du prix parce
qu'elle fait sur mesure je suppose que
ça coûterait très cher à la série
sterling en graphite du 5 au pitch il
faut compter dans les 900 euros ah oui
donc c'est le prix normal milieu de
gamme
c'est sûr quand on achète une série 900
euros on est un peu frais dans le milieu
de gamme comme celle ci avait failli à
thénia et donc on peut vous trouver il
ya un site internet
voilà et donc ben vous en savez un peu
plus sur les clubs de taille unique
c'est la grande mode et ça vaut
peut-être le coup d'essayer merci
beaucoup de gignac l'herbe
merci à patrice
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui fait un peu de cela et
b enfin on arrive quand même dans une
période qui est l'hiver où on se demande
toujours est-ce qu'on va jouer et
reconnaître dont fait pour jouer comment
il faut s'habiller pour pas de trop pour
brosser voix voire choquant même pour
pouvoir jouer sans semble s'en être
comme comme un bibendum là comme ça
c'est qu'il peut pour but alors je suis
avec yolan bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vous êtes à golf plus beau de tous tout
à fait et on va parler avec vous devez
tout d'abord un peu technique alors déjà
sur vous et un taux qui passe voit bien
exactement l'incontournable duplique
l'incontournable tenue de plus donc il
peut se porter aussi bien en fin de
saison 1 au final aussi bien en période
estivale qu'en période de l'hiver ont la
particularité c'est que on est vraiment
sur un vêtement qui est complètement
imperméable donc par rapport à la saison
actuelle ça permet vraiment pouvoir
jouer dans des conditions humides en
restant à l'aise la particularité des
vêtements de pluie donc un pantalon qui
étrangères assure pantalon de pluie
pendant exactement et une veste donc ce
sont des vêtements qui sont faits dans
des matériaux légers en général
respirant quand on porte une tenue de
pluie il faut en dessous avoir
différentes épaisseurs n'est qu'un hiver
et une bonne tenue des prix c'est vous
comptez un peu vrai combien entrée de
gamme alors entrée de gamme on va
compter aux alentours de
150 euros pour une veste sens oui 100
130 150 euros pour une veste un pantalon
il faut compter aussi environ alors là
on est à l'abri de la pluie
mana il faut avoir chaud aux mains et là
vous avez des moufles et qui sur spécial
dolphin exactement des moufles spécial
golfe évidemment qu'ils sont chaudes qui
sont déperlante la petite poche elle a
été conçue pour mettre des chaufferettes
à l'interné regardez c'est ça le petit
chaufferette alors c'est vrai ça c'est
bien c'est bien pour le ski c'est bien
pour le golf exactement 1 pour s'aimer à
oui c'est très bien ça non à la bouffe
le chauffante donc c'est exactement ça
se trouve on a deux rapports de rabat
qui se met dix ressortent sur les
oreilles donc des petits rabat qui sont
en polaire la particularité de cette
casquette donc on voit bien ici c'est
une casquette divers elle est en
gore-tex donc le gore tex donc une
casquette chaude complètement
imperméable et un minimum respirante et
j'ai dans les mains alors ça c'est une
chaussure ça c est bien ça c'est une
chaussure technique sa chaussure
technique pour les nerfs donc
spécialement conçu pour pour la période
hivernale
donc on est sur une chaussure
qui est en simili cuir ça ressemble à
une bottine vous avez donc un show 100
qui est classique et donc en choissant
qui est recouvert d'une sorte de
membrane avec une fermeture éclair à
l'avant et ce qui permet vraiment
d'avoir un produit là encore
complètement imperméable et qui protège
vraiment en cas d'humidité ensuite
idéalement quand il fait assez frais il
faut superposer les couches donc faut
pas hésiter
voilà même salle mais un peu engoncé
alors il faut pas être trop engoncé donc
c'est pour ça qu'on va essayer de
superposer maximum trois couches
différentes un acteur peut être par
exemple ce qu'on appelle les baisses
d'ailleurs donc ce sont les premières
couches combien elle même la peau qui
sont très stretch et qui sont bien
isolante et ensuite on peut porter un
polo à manches longues par exemple par
dessus ou même directement un pull
windstopper donc avec avec les membranes
coupant et par exemple comme ce que je
porte ici un vêtement de les lui ou une
doudoune sans manches
donc voilà il n'y a plus d'excusé pour
parler jouer l'hymne et non merci
beaucoup diraient non merci à vous
vous en avez assez de cela ici vos drive
aujourd'hui le tips de la semaine est
pour vous l'astuce du jour
c'est après hamac swing habituel viser
la balle au retour avec le bout du grip
[Musique]
prise d'élan naturel bout du groupe perd
la balle
finies les files maintenant à vous de
jouer
le bout du grip vers la balle c'est la
fin du slice merci de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro 2 par 78
[Musique]